as we begin the new year I believe it is
important to move forward to keep our
gaze fixed upon the Horizon we don't
want to spend too much time looking back
dwelling on the past yet I must say that
I do begin this year in a bit of a
reflective mood because 2022 was in many
ways a landmark year in my own life
began with my episode of Dr Phil in
early January a week after that episode
air I aired I was off to Africa filming
our at the time still secret documentary
project what is a woman which would be
released on the first day of pride month
in June of 2022 and go on to become one
of the most influential and talked about
documentaries of the current century in
the fall we exposed and brought down
Vanderbilt's child mutilation program
which led to our rally to end child
mutilation which was attended by upwards
of 3 000 people which led to the
introduction of legislation Banning
child gender transitions in the state of
Tennessee
all of that and we still found time to
do other things like raise awareness
about you know important issues like
translucent mermaids and satanic anime
so there's a lot going on
in 2022 and I'm very proud of all of
those accomplishments
and though I don't I don't I don't do it
for the awards I don't do it for the
accolades I still appreciate and am
humbled by them when they come which is
why I must take a moment to thank the
prominent left-wing publication the new
Republic which in the lead up to the new
year uh last week published a long
article awarding me
the title and trophy that I think I
worked very hard all year to earn this
is their headline transphobe of the Year
Matt Walsh the right-wing writer and
podcaster has raised his profile by
spreading grotesque conspiracy theories
about grooming and pedophilia in the
lgbtq community
yes facing stiff competition from the
likes of Tucker Carlson and Chris Ruffo
in Libs of tick tock and others I was
still given the prestigious title of
transphobe of the year the writer Indigo
Olivier explains why the honor went to
me she writes quote from book bands to
bomb threats 2022 has been characterized
by a disturbing rise in right-wing
violence brought on by the viral moral
Panic of very online fear mongers and
the biggest target of this Mayhem has
been the transgender Community figures
like Libs of tick tocks Chaya reichik
Tucker Carlson Ben Shapiro and the
Manhattan institute's Chris Ruffo have
joined conservative politicians in
flooding right-wing Airwaves with hate
speech and misinformation on issues like
gender affirming care and children's
sports but in a year when transgender
day of remembrance was marked by a mass
shooting at lgbtq nightclub in Colorado
Springs one man stands out from the
crowd Matt Walsh
I've already decided that I want this
person to deliver the eulogy at my
funeral which I think she'll be more
than happy to do actually but we're just
getting started it says quote the deli
wire columnist and podcast host has made
the name for himself by demonizing
medical professionals and pushing
conspiracy theories about grooming and
pedophilia in the lgbtq community if the
Club Q shooter is a lone wolf attacker
we should consider Walsh The Unofficial
pack leader while the bodies were still
warm the host of the Matt Walsh show
would log on to say quote if drag shows
are causing this much chaos and violence
why do you insist on continuing to do it
if according to you it's like putting
people's lives at risk if the effort to
have men cross-dress in front of
children is putting people's lives at
risk why are you still doing it it's a
crowded field but the new Republic has
crowned Walsh 2022's transphobe of the
year
So based on my reading of this it seems
that the transphobe of the Year
competition was it was very stiff
competition it came down to the wire at
the end and I finally pushed ahead of
the pack by making the exceedingly
obvious and basic observation documented
in that paragraph
which is that you know by the Groomer's
own account there has been Mass violence
and Chaos in response to drag
performances for children
now this account is entirely fictional
but that's beside the point the point is
that if it's true that exposing children
to drag
has caused this violent backlash
then you know it stands to reason that
one way to stop the violence would be to
Simply stop sexually harassing children
at drag shows
so if you really think that inviting
children to your drag show will put your
life at risk and yet you still do it
anyway
that only goes to show how totally
dedicated you are to grooming you're
apparently willing to Martyr yourself
for the cause
which just makes you all the more
deranged that's the point
anyway back to the article with a little
bit about my origin story it says Walsh
launched his fetid career in the same
manner as many of the worst of the
right-wing swamp conservative talk radio
Walsh has since gone on to create Johnny
The Walrus an allegorical children's
picture book about a boy who pretends to
be a walrus it reached number one on
Amazon's lgbtq bestsellers list and the
overall best sellers list by the way and
what is a woman a feature-length
documentary on gender ideology since his
early years in radio he's gone from a
bog standard shock jock vibe to a preppy
Fountain of increasingly weird far-right
obsessions Media Matters lgbtq program
director Arie Drennen has followed
Walsh's studied transformation which
he's changed his appearance based on his
audience
she said quote watching his early videos
it's really obvious that he wanted to
become famous today Walsh Sports a beard
and flannels and describes himself as a
Theocratic fascist on Twitter where he
has 1.2 million followers he says the
title can be interpreted in two ways
literally or as a joke
yes the people who are clinging
desperately onto my coattails reporting
on my every statement like I'm the pope
issuing infallible proclamations to the
faithful attaching themselves to me like
Barnacles on the side of a ship and
doing it all for clout
are concerned that I'm the one who is
trying too hard to be famous
and in their version of events okay in
their version of events I wanted to be
famous so much that I
grew a beard
and wore flannels
because everybody knows that's the first
step to fame and fortune
they they have it pegged I have to say
they've got it I can I still remember
the day A couple of years ago I'll never
forget I was thumbing through a Bass Pro
Shop catalog dreaming of one day
becoming wealthy and renowned when
suddenly my eyes fell on a Carhartt
flannel and I said to myself yes this is
it this is the ticket
and the rest is history
now I'm not going to read through too
much more of this but the next paragraph
I think is worth some attention it says
quote
I am literally a Theocratic fascist I do
indeed believe that my religious beliefs
should be forced on people by the
government and not just the government
but a government headed by me as a
dictator Walsh said in a 2019 video for
the daily wire before referencing his
recent Twitter tirade against white
condiments Mayo cream cheese ricotta
tartar sauce sauce ranch dressing and my
Theocratic fascist dictatorship all of
those condiments will be confiscated
prohibited and anyone who's caught with
Contraband like say ranch dressing will
face execution and a 50 fine
are you in on the joke like I said this
guy is deeply weird
now I fail to see anything weird about
wanting to execute people who use ranch
dressing ranch dressing tastes like
buttermilk mixed with like pool water
okay it's disgusting
what else are we supposed to do with
ranch dressing users except kill them
I'm open to other Solutions but nobody's
offering any so I've started this
conversation I started years ago what do
we do about people using ranch dressing
I have one idea we could kill them all
if you have other
brainstorms that you want to throw out
there go ahead and do it
I'm just getting the conversation
started is all
back to the article one more time it
says this guy is deeply dangerous as
well Walsh's most disturbing narratives
have centered on children in August
after Walsh called for an organized
effort against medical facilities that
butcher children Boston Children's
Hospital home to the First Pediatric and
Adolescent transgender health program
received its first bomb threat
Walsh undeterred by the real world
effect of his fear-mongering continued
to push the claim that the hospital was
mutilating children
which I was pushing that claim by the
way because that's exactly what they
were doing so it's
pushing a client it's not really well
it's a claim but it's a claim of what's
actually
happening and so uh and and it really
wasn't a claim at all actually it was
more of a like pointing to see here's
here's what they're doing and here are
videos of them talking about what
they're doing
anyway it says when the hospital
received its second bomb threat in early
September Walsh claimed it was a false
alarm and he left his hoax before
turning his attention to Vanderbilt
University Medical Centers trans Health
Clinic Walsh is very much against the
idea that people should be free to be
who they are so much so that he's led a
stochastic Terror campaign against the
trans Community which he says he plans
on personally taking to the streets if
the proud boys are as some say modern
day brown shirts they may have found an
unlikely leader in Matt Walsh
yes that's me leader of the proud boys
I'm not sure that I've ever even met a
proud boy but I am their leader which
comes as news to them and also to me
but if you've listened to all of this so
far
and you've thought to yourself
well this isn't fair
I mean why are they just calling Matt a
trans Folk he's also a racist
don't worry they make sure to include
that Accolade at the end they say while
he reserves the worst hatred for the
trans Community Jason Campbell a senior
researcher at Media Matters says it's
important to point out that Matt Walsh
is also a racist he's becoming this
champion of white rights
they then make note of my translucent
mermaid activism before concluding with
this quote Walsh is ready to adapt on
the fly as various outrages and panics
flit from fashionable to played out on
the right quote I I don't think it's I
don't think this moment of anti-trans
Hysteria is going to last forever
Drennan said I would not be surprised if
whatever the next right-wing moral Panic
is we see Matt Walsh once again at the
Forefront having conveniently forgotten
his fixation on trans people perhaps in
years to come he'll find new ways to
take home tnr's accolades for scoundrels
oh you can count on that I will find
many more ways to upset you in 2023 I
guarantee no question about it
except that if I could just clarify one
thing
I am not going to move on from
or forget
what you call my anti-trans hysteria
quote unquote until until the trans
movement has been totally and completely
destroyed that much I can promise you
I want it to be completely laying in Ash
in ruin that's what I want
now to that end we did make major
inroads last year the trans movement was
running rough shot over the culture for
years with basically no opposition and
that has now changed
and you on the left have noticed that
and you're panicking
and you're hoping that we'll be just
sort of happy with the battles we've won
so far and then we'll just move on to
something else
but your hopes are in vain
because we're out to win the entire War
and we will
so stay tuned that'll do it for this
portion of the shows and move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed